attention jean michel maire vous vous
retournez vous nous chanter la chanson
merci lot il a même pas réviser sans
décoller on voit qu'il n'a pas du tout
beau c'est bien allez c'est parti
merci afin de nous ôter tous nos
complexes aux gars de l'est on nous
donne des cours sur le sexe aux gays
on apprend la bicyclette
le gîte est repéré exact
merci en tout cas jean michel merde
c'était super c'est qu'en soient les
thierry bon attention c'est parti
afp deux maillots time after time out of
mind centers bête comité de no cry micex
a aimé d'un fuel queen we are the
champions we retient les bravos bordeaux
un championnat qui va prendre la guitare
et la chanson des cabanons laisse un
ballon pour lequel j arrive à nous
rappeler les règles à kenji il peut
jouer aussi
alors natasha st-pier à l'inattention
vous aimez la photo martin non mais vous
pouvez pas pour tourner nos petites face
à la sauce et sincère sur natacha on les
écoute car dans le sud de la louisiane
eh bien cette fois on sait canada d'état
à l'égard des tas de femmes qui tue sion
bat même lent que moi et quand ils font
de la musique c'est celle de rue
festives et michel fugain
oui les canadiens alors avec elle alors
jean-luc lemoine jean luc lemoine ils
changent jamais non mais bon allez c'est
parti dans les miroirs chinois dans le
bleu des photos dans le regard d'un chat
dans les aides un oiseau d'un arbre dans
la couleur de l'eau je te suis
jean pierre françois je te survivrai à
lézat belmont à ibos qu elles ne sont
pas du tout déjà tant qu'homme album
chaque jour deux jours laissez le moi
encore un peu
mathieu non éditée à fond et génère non
mon dieu mon dieu a battu âge que j'ai
péché
[Applaudissements]
on est con à l'égalité alors allez-y
nabila c'est à vous elle à laquelle
fallait pas caché le ballon derrière sow
la ville at c à et on y va
ça sent pas du tout la mer juste nabila
pouvait refaire juste allez c'est parti
alors il va hors d'elle quand on rentre
sur la piste allez vous retrouver
claquer 10 bis
quoi qu'elle dise oui attention
busch inbev avait pas besoin de ballons
d'hélium à
c'est ça rien j'ai pas la gagner c'est
ça ça m'a dit bon à part moi ça fait pas
à les y ait brûlé
et aux vendéens
autour
vous allez vivre chanson je connais mais
le tisseur 12
[Musique]